[Musique]
les chéris je vous ai demandé
aujourd'hui pour les téléspectateurs
d'avouer quelque chose que vous faites
et que vous alors julien je sais votre
très cool donc si vous ne la voulez pas
je vais le dire mais je le dis c'est
quoi je suis père gênés 1-2 ya une cour
qui est pas très loin d'ici
jade et donné 2 donc je jouais là mais
moi je vais leur deuxième avoir
bourlingué le premier il ya une cour où
on prend polaire certains fument et puis
j'étais allée va donner un coup de fil à
la cour on m'a dit antennes dans une
minute et à ce moment là je ma personne
j'ai très envie de faire pipi ce jour là
il y avait deux voitures garées aux
canards d'oies qui ça va pas faire
plaisir il y avait un 4 4 et une super
voiture de sport et je me suis dit comme
étaient entre les deux voitures
j'ai finalement n'ont pas choisi le 4 4
et la voiture de sport et j'ai fais pipi
sur la portière de la voiture de sport
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'hésitais entre le quatrième trimestre
est acquis et il a pissé sur votre
voiture
non mais c'est pas là moi j'ai fait du
vent dans le fond vestiaires merci j'ai
un autre truc avoué sur julien courbet
jouanno c'est que il avoue mater un peu
dans les loges quand les fils au change
les anciens studios il y avait un gré
sans s'émouvoir quand j'anime et le
vendredi que je vous remplacez je
prenais je venais briefé et j'attendais
toujours que vous soyez et en sortant de
la cabine qu'elle sortait alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait ce soir alors je vais
t'expliquer tu vas parler un petit peu
il est même arrivé de jeter un ou deux
petits coups et j'ai vu j'ai vu moi je
les bureaux c'est évidemment par an ces
espèces
oui c'était une sorte de string
[Applaudissements]
bertolucci jouera également sa partie il
attendait que je sois parti et j'ai vu
que roger dirai ça vous va très très
bien le papier toilette comme ça on
[Applaudissements]
aurait tellement ça me que j'ai oublié
de l'enlever parce que je parlera aussi
de tpm prochaine et je veux dire la
drogue sur isabelle valérie bénaïm vous
êtes ckoi 107 bronzé vous mais parce que
je vous ai dit j'étais parti avec mon
fils oui c'est vrai
voilà lorsque vous avez un truc à vous
et valérie eux alors ce que je fait
qu'il ne faut pas faire part c'est que
je laisse tout allumée chez moi tout le
temps tout le passé ça va nous occuper
l'une avouables bah oui il faut pas le
faire chier mais ne le fait pas parce
attachez vous même
mais j'en ai rien à [ __ ] une vidéo je
[Applaudissements]
triche albert oui moi je sais rien de
totalement illégal mais il se trouve que
[Rires]
je suis en fin de parcours visiblement
dans tous les gens qui distribuent des
prospectus publicitaires dans les boîtes
aux lettres excuses mais tu es une
coccinelle juste la réal ouimet c'est
pas très grave
excuse moi l'école al jardine notre
latin auxerre 1 2 alors oui c'est un
vrai c'est fait alors j'arrive un soir
et demain soir à 21h30 c'est la
coccinelle dans mes séries vous avez
fait quoi qu'on veut ben oui ça m'est
rapport est que géraldine mais ça peu
après c'est ce qu'il faut pour que ça se
réalise
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est par la musique jean-michel non
merci j'ai bien parce que j'ai bien aimé
parce que la réponse a été direct non
non merci écrasé pas abattu car je sai
et veut jouer dessus autres de le faire
là est ce que tu proposes de l'on veut
non je fais tout tout [ __ ] en l'air à
tous et bon merci est excusez moi ne
parlait plus vous entretenir alors c'est
quoi et donc du coup j'ai ma boîte aux
lettres est toujours rempli le
prospectus ont toujours en ce moment
plus avec la campagne électorale et du
coup en fonction de l'humeur kojak mes
voisins chez des voisins des relations
compliquées que voisin ce que j'ai un
chien edgar qui quand je suis pas là il
aboie tout le temps excusez moi c'est
l'interview de 30 millions d'amis et du
coup j'ai souvent des voisins qui se
peignent est donc en fonction de ceux
qui se plaignent le plus je prends tout
mais ce prospectus est tout ce que je
trouvais je bourre leur boîte hull est
pour jusqu'à cela déborde très
dépouillée mais pas les boîtes aux
lettres
d'accord mais ya renoncé à quoi non mais
en plus maintenant très peu dans la
sarthe c'est toi c'est vous aime bien
dans votre immeuble non merci alors là
vous allez voir maxime khédive avoué un
jour j'étais chez moi nous et les
traiter c'est manger
en fait les août périmés
devant j'ai l'habitude de prendre le
métro et le train à la recherche des
scoops et des informations inavouables
c'est que je porte souvent des écouteurs
je fais croire que j'écoute de la
musique
sauf que j'écoutais absolument pas la
musique je ne mets absolument rien et
j'écoute toutes les conversations par
exemple j'ai pris le train pour revenir
débauche où j'ai passé le week end est
devant moi un couple d'amis et elle a un
couple de que je ne connaissais pas et
il commençait un petit peu ce à ce fight
excusez-moi biowin prétoire donné à
coxyde et je vais faire un verre au bar
c'est dire donc finale il peut faire une
vidéo ce soir alors que vous dire que
j'observe tout je vois tout j'entends
tout mais je ne dis rien disait c'est
quoi alors la forme embrasser qu'il
n'écoute pas de musique dans son truc
j'écoute les conversations observe un
gros des fugees norvège mais c'est pas
bon il va votre beau et préfets des
bagages
je veux finir avec les deux personnes
est-ce que vous avez un truc qui n'a
voix jean valette et des sms quand je
compte y allait du coup quand je me fais
arrêter je pleure et donc comme ça enfin
ça va ils ont pitié tubage retraites
faites moi voilà mes ou sur le bas-côté
suis au fait la paix du fait que c'est
pourquoi je vous arrête
didier deschamps l'a
drake non mais j'aime impressionne
tellement que j'ai pas besoin de me
forcer je pleure déjà en plus il ne
reste que quatre mots sur mon permis
d'explorer c'est pourquoi je vous arrête
peur
meichtry boîte ça et vous n'avez pu
travailler sur le permis très vite
jean-luc lebron oui bonjour à quoi un
truc que j'aime bien faire et que les
gens disent qu'il faut pas faire wi fi
chroniqueur attouchements
j'avoue j'aime bien manger que les
doigts moi aussi moi aussi oui oui mais
l'épreuve
non parce que j'aime bien manger qui
dormait mais pas les miens j'aime bien
prendre les mains de quelqu'un pouvait
pas savoir est franchement si je devais
prendre les mains des mois les plus
proches reprendre la main d'estelle
denis
mes pieds les confiance wheelman
beinheim rugby ça c'est pas vos pieds
pour une addition aurait déjà l'oignon
donc
[Applaudissements]
géraldine manier un jour j'ai lu le
livre de 22 pages
je me suis arrêté le 19 juin on n'est
pas si loin
non oui au début quand j'étais écrivain
j'ai écrit à peu près mais trois quatre
premiers romans des jarrets déjà ça sur
le voyage déjà normalement bon là on est
con l'entend pas cette phrase
normalement moi j'étais écrivain j'avais
écrit mais trois quatre premiers romans
vas-y ouais je faisais le tour des
librairies
ouais on voir si mon livre a été vendu
ouais et souvent ils se retrouvaient
sous les tables ou dans les étagères
perdu est donc le premier et je le
mettais devant way ou le rebelle salut
c'est moi
bah ouais c'était un peu long tour
j'avais adoré ça
vas-y ouais bah si jacques quoi vous
impressionne avec graver votre plagne
c'est très drôle oui alors vous saviez
vous et vous aviez si pipi dans la
bouteille de quelqu'un oui mais ça c'est
défaire c'est toujours en rapport avec
le baby est arrivé donc si on fait
suivre in log quand je suis arrivé dans
cette équipe
j'aime bien sortir pendant les pauses
prendre l'air et j'aime bien c'est vrai
faire pipi dehors et je faisais arriver
on pique contre les poubelles c'est
vraiment un truc de mec de tf1 et je
crois que sa barbe
le mot s'est passé entre toulon que je
faisais pipi d'or il ya une note qui a
été fait
l attention la direction de h2o pour
qu'on me rêve percute d'arrêter de
pisser dans la cour donc j'ai arrêté de
piste dans la cour par bon c'est vous
qui puissiez mener un coup oui mais un
jour il a pissé sur un mec épicé sur sa
voiture
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais pas leur argent alassane
vannes qu'elle a fait avec son mari neil
les spis gilles fait lorsque la lgv à
être saouls a fait la pole
oui ils baignent enfin là on ne voit pas
alors oui non alors qu en fait j'adore
aller à la plage quoi manger j'ai ma
petite serviette bleue ma grande
serviette
il est et je vais à la plage alors moi
j'ai mon petit transistor des années 90
à piles il est tout gris marche bien
avec une tête en ballerines demandé et
donc du coup j'arrive à la place way
admettons isabelle est à la plage était
allongé à la plage à moustoir la plante
voilà elle est allongée à la place je
veux tu vois la plage ne mange pas la
tâche
je mets ma petite serviette à côté
d'elle et mon petit transistor et 11
juillet j'adore le tour de france donc
je mets ma petite radio à fond j'écoute
le tour de france et quand les français
gagnent donc elle me connaît pas les à
la poche s'agisse des choses comme ça à
côté de la fille à côté de moi et ça
semble pas convaincu l'électronique
tu vas bientôt merdé l'équipe aura pas
des gens comme ça allait on termine
alors est ce qu'il ya où sont vos
dalmatiens à la moyenne et un truc je
vais au restaurant pour faire rire mes
camarades alors sa joie je ne sens pas
du tout non c'est très simple j'adore me
mettre plein de petits curbans entre les
dents qui se fait grâce à taïwan
vous avez recruté comme déteste vraiment
qu'on bouche les oreilles mais des tout
petits tampons dans les oreilles non d
sinon je fais des concours de mieux même
il a été contraint de reconnaître le
prêtre nommé olmo avec ses chars combien
de gens savent que c'est un concours ils
s'inscrivent à bonjour toi qu'on commet
art is it le baça départ il ya la
période des amours c'est aussi le grand
prix de formule 1 de monaco
coupé par mad love avec le passé la
terre et mer alors fait la période
d'appel de mons et voilà sinon c'est pas
c'est vrai quoi et vos chars ils vous
répondent oui il vous faut quoi même à
l'échappement la discussion a dit non
cet achat
[Rires]
je vais pas mentir j'y avais pensé je me
suis dévoué et ce tour de table
je pourrais faire pendant huit heures
vraiment vous avez avoué des trucs fous
bonne nouvelle on va vous amener des
cure-dents vous allez pouvoir le faire
la main sur les collèges en étudiant les
trois là sur mois déjà mais on va vous
en amener d'autres chez toyota on est
allé en acheter la voix ils sont partis
faire des courses vous voulez d'autres
choses qui voulaient des aubergines des
pressions ce soir pardonnez moi pourquoi
vous avez des cure dents sur vous pour
animer l'émission parce que au cas où il
a travaillé chez les jeunes l'hygiène
excusez moi